hey everyone this is Steve with collider
and we are here at Sundance in our
studio in Park City I want to give a
huge thank you before we get to talk
about good one I want to give a huge
thank you to film EO for being our
sponsor we would not be able to be here
supporting Indie Cinema and everything
we're doing without them uh Sundance is
expensive to cover so just letting you
know but one huge thank you to filo and
um they're shattering the boundaries by
placing the power to greenl films in the
hands of creators and fans you can learn
a lot more about them by visiting their
website
film. how you guys doing super great
thank you uh I really want to start with
a sincere congratulations on your movie
I heard you made it in 12 days and I'm
blown away and you also filmed in the
wilderness and on location like
everything you guys did I'm like I don't
understand so before we get started no
one watching this interview will have
seen the film yet so who wants to bite
the bullet and like give the log line
what it's about I'll take I'll take that
one for the
team um it's about a teenage girl Sam
played by Lily uh who goes on a
backpacking trip in the woods with her
father James and her father's friend
that's me old friend uh the two men uh
there's some tension between them their
friendship is sort of expired and Sam
falls
into the role of mediator caretaker
contending with these two sort of
competing egos it's really a Coming of
Age film um about that moment when you
start to see the adults in your life um
your parents as the flawed complex
people that they are this is a little
bit of a jokey question but bear with me
um did youcast James from His Brilliant
work on Night Rider and Punky Brewster
early in his career it was from the a uh
the CBS after school special actually I
think was the one that got me in the
door uh my bad um I always like looking
when people are coming in like the imdp
profile and someone who's been in the
business for a long time and seeing the
very early work where you were like
ecstatic to get that role on Night Rider
Punky Brewster yeah praise the Lord yeah
I'm grateful for all that work oh and
also you're learning about acting like
and being on camera and absolutely I I
tell people when I did fantasm 2 was the
first lead I did in a picture and I
learned a lot about film making I'm so
grateful to those people yeah 100% so
one of the things I really uh loved
about this movie is just how like honest
it felt and just real you know and um it
didn't feel like uh it just and for the
three of you could you sort of talk
about reading a script like this and
what resonated with you about your
character and being in this film uh when
I first read the script uh it was
earlier on on
and I just
loved
feeling how Sam approaches life she's
she's very witty she's very clever she's
very patient and um I felt like I had a
lot to learn from her and I really
wanted to just dive deep and understand
this point in life that she's at cuz I
I'm around the same age
uh I resonated resonated a lot with mat
because you know he's he's sort of
having a midlife crisis and and um not
that I'm completely having a midlife
crisis right now but you know a little
bit um um completely lost sometimes and
uh grasping at for anything to really
you know keep him grounded and and happy
so yeah it's
really uh it was kind of easy to drop
into that a little bit emotionally
because you know anybody that's 54 and
you know kind of struggling year to year
and month to month to pay rent or
whatever you know just to try to keep a
to keep happy understands that it's a
struggle so it was really um it was uh
it felt great to be out in the woods
with these guys for two weeks and kind
of discover that so good oh thanks guys
too uh you know for me at this point in
my journey it's less about like what the
character is and more about like who am
I working with and what is a script and
that was really the draw for me well one
of the things about this is this is your
first feature and I'm curious how much
did you debate this what you wanted to
make as your first feature was it in
your head like is this the project like
or am I completely like out of my
mind uh it's just the one that happened
first got it uh for a lot of reasons you
know I we I I sort of designed the
script to be um
makeable with in a kind of um yeah
intimate way with people that I had
collaborated with on short films you
know with my community so um yeah I
don't know this this film just always
had um yeah we had a lot of luck along
the way and it it's it's the one that
came together first I believe this is
your first starring role so what was it
like getting that phone call or Zoom
where you found out that you are going
to be the lead in a
movie I was so excited to work with
India cuz the first time we'd met we met
up for coffee and we just talked about
art and film
and we barely even talked about the
movie we just got to know each other and
I really saw her character
and I just knew from then on I I really
wanted to work with her so I was very
happy so one of the things as you guys
made this in 12 days and it's not like
you were in a Sound Studio or like a um
a one-bedroom filming everything
dialogue you're in the wilderness on
location so talk about trying to do this
in 12 days and you you know you don't
have some like crazy budget to work with
you know what I
mean yeah a lot of thinking on our feet
and adapting to our surroundings
um but one of the beautiful things of
being outdoors is you're working with
available light and you can move quickly
and um yeah there was a lot you know a
lot to gain from from the the
environment even though it it was
challenging at times yeah I would say by
design it we had a lot of agility
options built in so we could pivot you
know it's a just if you're a first you
know if you're starting out as a
filmmaker
if you can write a small cast and cheap
locations it greatly enhances your
chances of getting the thing made
there's also um there's a scene I'm not
going to go into any specifics where you
guys have to jump in the water and I'm
just curious what is that like when you
are out in the middle of nowhere and
filming that specific scene oh I
completely blacked out the water was so
cold and I'm so bad with cold water and
I forgot how I got in and I came out and
I was like did I did I did I do a cannon
ball and they're like no you did a
really great dive and I was like okay
I'll take
it that's all I remember that was a fun
day and you know honestly I don't I
don't think I was really thinking about
the scene so much as I was just trying
to make my colleague crack
up I will add that uh after we wrapped I
forced myself to go swimming in that
water so that I could you know
commiserate with my colleagues here and
it was cold it was very cold uh one of
the things Danny is uh your character is
really not comfortable with silence so
can you sort of talk a little bit about
that and uh is it do you enjoy playing
someone who's doing things that you
agree with or disagree with like I I
butchered the way I said that but uh
let's just say like uncomfortable
silence uh I enjoy both I mean India
wrote Such a a fun script so I really I
had fun saying the lines and she um
allowed us to like you know go off
script and kind of do whatever we wanted
so it was super fun
to talk and talk and talk and talk it it
I I have a great time doing it but I
also don't like talking in public can
you
tell um so the silence parts were were
fun too I had a I had a gas two weeks of
just fun acting so I'm always curious
about the editing process because where
it's where it all comes together so how
did the film get shaped in the editing
room in maybe ways you weren't expecting
going in in in subtle ways uh one of our
producers Graham May
who uh is a filmmaker himself and edits
his own work uh edited the film he you
know produced the film and aded the film
and so was you know really intimately
involved in the creative process and
there are a few sequences um the water
sequence is one of them and uh the
campfire sequence where uh he had he he
did his version of it and just
discovered a a
um and an organic quality to the edit
that I could not I did not picture in my
head um that I think only comes from an
editor just really being uh afforded the
space to be in the footage and feel the
rhythm of it and without you know
outside voices so yeah it truly just
collaboration with graham yeah uh for
the all for all of you um when you when
you knew this the shooting schedule what
was the day or scene that you had
circled in terms of I am so nervous to
film this or I cannot wait to film
this I can't tell you which scene it it
is but I I would imagine people will
know what it is when they see it um the
third act what uh yeah yeah in the third
act the third act yeah Lily might know
what I'm talking about yeah I definitely
had I'm G to just say you guys navigated
that just so beautifully it's it's one
of my favorite parts of the film thank
you there are some uh very large page
count days with a lot of dialogue uh
that you know James and Danny in
particular the ones all the lines I I
was reminded
often about those page
counts traumatic stress we did did um I
I can't talk about spe you actually
didn't did you want to answer uh I think
Danny and I have the same day in mind
yeah one of the things and I can't talk
about it is I really loved and again I'm
not going to do spoils but the third act
um and the way that the film is just
honest with the way things happen and
the way people react to things uh it's
really great writing and it's just
honest to what people would do um uh you
know I don't really have a question
there I just wanted to say I'm glad that
you appreciate someone who's able to
express unvarnished truth and that again
I Circle back to why I wanted to do it
again who I was working with and the and
and what was on the page yeah it's just
a very you know um it's just very honest
you know and also if you don't mind talk
a little bit about your character is
like so much more mature than um for
than for her age you know cooking
cleaning like the grownup with the kids
yeah yeah no kidding um on and offset no
kidding well that's that's Sam's
character she um she plays all the roles
she's always in any given opportunity to
provide and and she takes that as a
moment of quality time with her dad and
whatever it is she'll take it I would
say that that kind of role playing has a
sacrifice absolutely I completely agree
I have so many more things to talk about
but the a I'm out of time and B I can't
spoil any aspect of this movie so it's
like when it eventually comes out we'll
do more you know we'll go deeper into
you know what I mean about other stuff
but uh definitely worth your time um
huge thank you to you guys coming in uh
good one uh hopefully it's get picked
Hope it's for sale I'm assuming or is it
it is for sale yeah um I really again
want to give a huge thank you to filo
for being our sponsor and allowing us to
be here and do interviews like this you
guys have a fantastic Sundance thank you
much you
too